starting his third season at the
University of Tennessee head coach he's
Jeromy Pruitt who joins us on program
good morning coach how's morale I'm
doing okay you guys got in the news well
you've been in the news for a couple
reasons another great recruiting class
but Phillip Fulmer says gonna have a
hundred thousand fans at the home games
there in the fall how how optimistic are
you that you'll have 100,000 fans
watching volunteers football well if
they completely open up the stadium I'm
sure there'll be a hundred thousand
people there for sure but do you think
there will be well I don't know about
that that's there's lots of time between
now and then how optimistic are you that
you can start the season on time you
know our Arab medical staff has done an
outstanding job getting our players back
and working a plan and through the SEC
you know we've done a nice job as
executing the plan and we've got to
continue to do that compare this June to
last year at this time well it's
obviously we started later you know and
it's been voluntary so you know it's
been more so with the players and the
strength staff as opposed with the
coaching staff so all the meetings have
been online so it's obviously a little
bit different are you allowed to
announce the number of players who have
tested positive I saw where Alabama
Clemson LSU it feels like that that's
been a team or school announcement what
about Tennessee yeah with all the
players that we've had in here and that
we've tested we've had zero positive
tests with the guys that we've tested
how often are they going to be tested
the rest of this summer well that will
be up to our medical staff you know
where our guys are going out for a
three-day weekend this weekend so
they'll have a plan when they come back
to get everybody within our program test
it more start over yeah you know we're
in these it's almost like day to day
coach trying to figure this out of you
know
you you know we keep saying well we're
gonna start on time and I keep telling
people and this is day-to-day you can
have those goals and we can wish for
that but what do you say to your players
as far as but whatever concerns they may
have
but what's your message to them yeah
we've been worried about the things that
we have control over so once we get in
here get in here and we have tests and
we we don't have negatives you know we
kind of control the our own surroundings
you know so within our program we've
done a very nice job of that this summer
we've got to continue to do that when do
you have full contact practice let's see
we start practice on August 7th so it's
it's 3 or 4 days after that I was
looking at the coach of the quarterbacks
you've coached against Bert when your
stay at Tennessee Jared Stidham to a
drew Locke Jake Fromm will Grier who was
the toughest to prepare for out of that
group well I'm sure all these guys
present different problems but you know
that's County in the past I'm kind of
looking Oh have a little bit of fun
coach come on I'm looking to the future
to see who we've got a completed yes
come on who was the toughest one out of
that group because I'm curious about
Stidham he seems a little bit more of a
mystery there to what we know a lot
about lock it feels like he's coming on
and not sure about Fromm and Greer but
tell me about Stidham well you know that
was a couple of years ago so you know
the system that he played in you know
they they really throw the ball more
down the field there's not a lot of rpoS
and stuff so you know we actually had a
good day against him I mean over the
last couple years it's been pretty
obvious in our league the guys that we
played against you know to has been as
good as anybody I've coached against in
a long time and I felt like Jake from
did a nice job far as managing you know
his offense over the last three years
that we competed does it help you were
high school quarter
I think went to college to be a
quarterback does it help as a defensive
quarter a defensive minded guy that
you've played the position does that
help at all well I think when you start
talking about defense if you want to be
good defense well you got to start from
the back end and work your way forward
so being able to eliminate explosive
plays really starts with the defensive
back so whether it's in the throw game
or squeezing the runs off so you know I
and I do think that probably my
experience as a as a quarterback in high
school helps me have a little bit better
understanding of what people are trying
to do offenses who plays the position
the way you played quarterback the way I
played quarterback mmm I would say most
of them play it much better than idea
yeah but do you know is it were you a
Brady like were you Rogers like an
option guy Cam Newton guy I wouldn't say
I was like any of those yeah do you have
any Alabama gear left no I don't got rid
of everything did you have a garage sale
no I just I had a lot of friends I could
just give it away where's your Tennessee
colors here you're kind of subdued today
I expected some orange here well this is
a shirt that they gave me to wear for
this interview all they give wait I got
a Hoosier I need checkerboard I need
something here here's your wardrobe guy
let me talk to him
you got talked to Roger Frazier come on
ROG give me some orange here man hey
well good luck with this season and all
these hurdles that we have coming up we
appreciate your time and good luck this
season coach thank you that's Jeromy
Pruitt he's former defensive coordinator
at Alabama and Tennessee Volunteers he
was eight I think spent eight years with
Coach Saban at Alabama